la corse une montagne dans la mer lille
revêt mille visages mille paysages
autant d'atouts pour le tourisme secteur
indispensable 24 % du pib
la corse est une terre de villégiature
depuis des siècles pour les européens le
tourisme de masse lui se développe à la
fin des années 50 et représente une
nouvelle manne économique
la corse sera sauvé par le profit que
l'on saura désormais tirer de ces
beautés naturelles inégal à des hôtels
se construisait en 1960 270 mille
touristes ont visité l'île selon un
reportage de l'époque
nous avons été charmés par tous nous
avons passé nous avons fait un voyage
merveilleux en champion fait tout le
tour de l'accord à partir des années
soixante dix les belges les néerlandais
les autrichiens mais surtout les
allemands font de la corse une
destination privilégiée
ils viennent en charter en groupe se
déplace au gré de circuits touristiques
une aubaine pour les professionnels du
tourisme sécurité enquête qui est très
bonne à tous les points de vue et
cheyrou nouvelle et elle se renouvelle
derache rtn demande pour les gens dans
les années 70 le tourisme connaît ses
premières perturbations tout est prêt
sur place pour accueillir un nombre de
visiteurs croissant mais en 1977 ils ne
sont pas aussi nombreux qu'attendu
le problème vient du manque de liaisons
aériennes et maritimes avec le continent
bonjour s'il vous plaît derrière la
carte postale la corse souffre d'une
image sulfureuse dans des années 70 et
80 les attentats nationaliste le
banditisme font hésiter des vacanciers
conséquence moins de retombées
économiques comme observé en 1984 dix
pour cent en moins ça fait 20 milliards
de centimes injecté
220 milliards de centimes de moi
injectés dans l'économie insulaire et
par voie de conséquence cela a réagi sur
l'ensemble du tissu économique à
l'exception de quelques années la corse
attirent les vacanciers les compagnies
aériennes low cost et la multiplication
des lignes maritimes ont favorisé le
tourisme en 2018 lille a totalisé 10
millions 500 mille nuitées trop de
touristes
en tout cas le président de l'assemblée
territoriale de corse a réfléchi à
limiter des flux touristiques
ce qui n'a pas ravi les commerçants du
marché d'ajaccio n'a jamais trop voilà
tories sont bienvenus la corsa en cette
saison à la suite de l'épidémie de coved
19 celle inverse tout l'enjeu est
d'attirer à nouveau la clientèle vers la
corse
durement touché désormais en zone verte
et ouverte aux voyageurs
[Musique]